au bar que oui alors vous êtes fatigant
pourquoi marca les chances de remporter
le flou parce que dans sa tête il ya
aucune chance qui ne remporte pas le
flambeau de gagner les 450 euros c'est
pareil 1 450 euros une somme folle avec
sandra évidemment rien ne l'empêchera
gagner les 450 euros ou n'approche pas
nouveau reflex si on décide que ce monde
peut être remportée par des gens qui
sont sympas celle qu il yal peut t'aider
non surtout pas sa capuche comme un bon
socialiste les a cités il est prêt sur
alarme qui me fera gagner ne fait pas
les cours vis il est très sympathique en
fait donc c'est pour ça qu'il a une
chance de gagner
tony tony qu'elle plus de chances de
remporter le flambeau c'est un jeu
sportif est là pour une fois il ya que
du sport est un peu sa dernière chance à
50 balais de se dire avec cette aventure
je vais gagner ma première place au club
la donne on vote contre vu ce soir moi
il ya quand même très très peu de choses
pour le rattraper et pourtant évidemment
nous mêler travail va pas des dégénérés
dit mais quoi physiquement elle est très
en forme mais c'est beaucoup de sport
elle est maligne elle est intelligente
mais non ouais j'en veux je suis cash
quoi tu fais un âge où j'ai pas tout lu
le scénario je suis incapable de vous
dire si j'étais lui ni ou pop
je pas cotiser mais si peu qu'il y
arrive quel sera le prochain aventuriers
éliminés vous serez en regardant le
prochain épisode du flambeau les
aventuriers de chewbacca bras
[Musique]